ziemlich viel sicherer jetzt mit dem
fall wenn man sich hier austoben konnte
und ich kann es mir gut vorstellen dass
man damit auch in der stadt dann auch
mit richtigen autos und fahrradfahren an
teilnehmern zu fahren ich denke nicht
dass es strengere regeln geben muss
sondern vielmehr dass die leute
verstehen dass sie die regeln befolgen
müssen und das versuchen wir den
personen auch nach und nach
nahezubringen und beizubringen und genau
dafür sind auch solche
fahrsicherheitstrainings wir heute
gedacht also besonders wichtig aus
meiner sicht um sicher durch den
straßenverkehr zu kommen ist natürlich
erstmal den eigenen sachverstand zu
benutzen das heisst vorausschauen fahren
die verkehrsregeln beachten und auch
andere verkehrsteilnehmer respektieren
zum anderen aber geht es natürlich auch
darum scooter spezifische dinge zu
berücksichtigen
dazu gehört zum beispiel dass man
idealerweise einen helm tragen sollte
wenn man die möglichkeit hat oder ein
dabei hat oder nicht zu zweit auf einem
scooter fahren weil das ist gefährlich
und verboten